I will go nice this year so I appreciate
that you came all the way to Yokohama to
to talk to me there's a lot going on in
the coming year in terms of events gif
the aikikai and so on
I guess we'll work on the assumption
that in spite of the coronavirus
everything takes place as planned
let's hope you shall see if that's the
case but before we start talking about
that what I like to talk to you about is
your own personal journey through Aikido
okay because that's I've looked around
you know googled your name and so huh in
we know each other but actually I know
very little about your your past
experience and I thought that'd be a
good idea to have you walk us through
that those beginnings and so on yeah
okay I started Aikido in 1982 in the
Netherlands I'm born in Ireland at that
time was on the direction of firkin Eska
sensei who came off from England and he
was a technical director it was also the
time that it was a small Federation
about 400 people and if you were a
showdown you were already a senior so
that was the climate of that time so
when I become after seven years every
day trading showdown that was lit the
level that time I asked my teacher what
should I do for need on he said he said
just relax
wait a moment just to elect who doesn't
mean so I I thought they don't know I
thought they don't know so at that time
I was also always oka from the passing
she hunts and that most it was your
godson say at that time so cut me forced
first hakama for yoko doesn't say and so
or the certain point he invited me to go
to homo dojo and didn't know what it
means so I just bought the ticket went
to the humble and we're at my rug sucker
I came down and I said I'm here okay
and then they realized I supposed to
stay young guy dead for some time so
it's the first time I stayed three
months in hombu dojo at that time Kimura
though she was still alive so and I was
the dashi so
trained a lot and I could hope to Aikido
so I feel fairly home at home over there
so I came back to Holland and work my
ass off to get another ticket to go
again but the time and my wife got
pregnant she was very clever cause he
thought if I if it doesn't do that he
was so but I was a time also that the
Yamaguchi asked me to stay he said to
stay can you stay sorry I cannot stay
because my wife is pregnant and she
lives in the Netherlands so I said oh
yeah it go to Christian so it was at
that time in 1990-91 I didn't know
Christian at all it was just so I went
to Paris and said hello here am i
yamaguchi set me and he watched me is it
ok sorry but it was lately but strange
because I had to commute from Armstrong
to Paris and I did it twice a week I
come a commute so I had all four Falls
and I drove a completely till the end at
that time it was 992 I think I was one
of the first non French - she it was the
time that bill no cons are 18 and 19 I
was already 30 and so my journey
actually after whom Adagio and I
realized that Christian was able to make
professionals so I decided to stay a
long time so I stayed almost team I
think 10 years I don't know anymore
until 2000 or something at that time
more and more forums came and especially
from Germany but I was the same PI at
that time and I started my own Club in I
think 1994 and by the time I was young
dance and on and on I don't know anymore
I made a very big Federation
my Federation was at that time around
2,000 people 2,500 people I don't know
anymore
I was the biggest so I was asked to make
by the government to organize an
umbrella organization for the
Netherlands but I did in 2009 and this
long time later but for me it was a very
important thing because I saw that I was
very fragment everywhere so I sort of
the strange because I remember one time
I was an Ambo kite doing a demonstration
and the the one who did the speaker said
now there's Aikido they pretend to be
harmonious but there are the most-played
group I ever saw and I was like thank
you but I thought he's right he's right
he's right
so I thought that should Mon the case so
I decided to table to unite my country
and make one umbrella organization what
I succeed in 2009 2009 v Rome were
recognized entities went in one umbrella
and to seal it those who came so I give
my offer and etc etc so that was my
short period and then I realized somehow
besides the technical development as a
professional it said so it was also poor
to a political side but at that time was
split to the technicians and the
politicians they said job but you know
if you get give you reach a certain
seniority you should carry the weight of
during the politics with such ways I
keep politics that was my decision well
actually there's quite a bit to
unpacking here because first I guess the
answer that the question is you can see
it both ways in terms of the Harmonia
Aikido in terms of Aikido being I think
by design something that's supposed to
be open to many interpretations yeah so
in this sense perhaps it makes sense
that everybody does their little thing
in you know in their own corner but of
course if you think about Aikido in
terms of something joining energies and
so on then it makes sense to unify them
and I always wonder what's really the
best for the for perhaps s for the
discipline itself but for the
practitioners is do everybody doing
their own thing you know by themselves
and so on
Oh gathering because if you gather those
people I guess the number of question
that going to be a rising such as do you
centralized grading systems you who is
representative whenever there is
something happening no but you know I
think for me it was like the same when
you watch the development of a country
for instance an old days you had cleanse
and every clan had a fleck and f-words
very happy to have his own flag and but
cleanse are doing they fight each other
right and one day somebody says let's
make a nation right and you unite all
the clans to a nation so in Aikido it
requires and such maturity to quit to
come to that when you're young some
dungeon down you want you have you feel
your own power
you want your own flag and my flag is
the best or something like that and we a
little bit more cheery realized world or
how reflects to and maybe there are good
neighbors right and also they decide
well if I kiddo is the spirit of quest
for yourself is a kind of Liberty net
and if there are more home recognized
energies every home recognized and it
should have its own lineage with home
instead of grading but doesn't mean you
can't cooperate with other and the
cooperation can be a joint seminar or
can be in case of a common license
system for teachers so the many feels
incorporated especially for a young
generation they don't care which Fleck
you carry so the kids want us to just
into Aikido together so I think there
are many elements it and now I am let's
say now F is I see different stage of
development each country some country
are still in the states of having their
own clan with reflects and some started
saying maybe we can unite right so
that's a I think it's more kind of
mature nests in Aikido of course if
that's the case that mature nurses also
be cultivated by Japan but some case
Japan if you watch the organization
chart of Japan you see in the morning
most different Federation's right so
watching that and watch the history of
Japan where a lot of civil war like
situations right
it took also a long time here to get
together all right so if you approach
from that side I have a positive feeling
about that one day everyone realized he
should work more work more together
right I truly believe that that the only
way you can communicate and do relation
stuff on Fridays if you train together
so if you're common base by training
there's automatically you create respect
so let's also many philosophy now we
should train together and then things
happen by itself actually right the
thing with Aikido like you said that
some countries are more mature than
others and so on I mean the one that
comes to mind and I may get some grief
or for saying that but France being one
of the countries where Aikido was first
exported still has that clear divide
with between two major groups and many
other groups as well and I don't see
that you know changing anytime soon
it is changing actually yes because of
course you remember the time that that I
could all from the well-respected Xian
Tamar was called unique in a new
question was what more set in the sense
being different as from Ikea I and
Christian tshe was somehow aligned with
Christian but was not on Japanese right
so you artists do use to Messick
federations over Christian size
Federation was thirty thousand not about
20,000 sided in the thousands right but
at one point they were summoned by the
government to do something together so
to create an a United Federation this
was of course with the exception of the
International representation and and
what did the grading right so now for
the first I heard talks that I think
about and the timeframe can be different
maybe now or four or five years later
that Eva becomes the member of the ideas
but in that case which the the strong
condition that the history of Scottish a
has been let's say valued that he
becomes the technical represent for the
country addressing because she is the
first had she done non-japanese and that
time that is of only possible since
Tamura passed away ten years ago so that
there's no need anymore for this super
flag behavior I call it like that but
everyone was very devoted and I think
with wade through sense to tamura-san
say what the same case will forty che
and I think that is changing especially
also that they see that if they don't
cooperate or don't do that you see made
more flat splitting everywhere right so
especially case of France where you have
a government who is very strongly
organized and actually expect
but I could be on one roof well that
gives you some strong incentive to
change let's say it like that
interestingly if you look at the history
of French Aikido of perhaps I don't know
much about Netherlands but compare let's
say to English I'd you do right yeah
France has a Shia majority of
practitioners that would recognize
themselves within the umbrella of the
aikikai whereas if you go to England you
can have a lot of people practicing
yoshinkan aikido tamaki aikido and so
here we are talking about grouping
people of aikikai lineage oh yeah
have you experienced any incidents of
groups from different lineage grouping
together for instance in in the
Netherlands are we only talking about
aikikai related groups or no no right to
umbrella organization Netherlands one is
for the aikikai normal recognized
entities who are together member for the
IAF and that at the moment are seven out
of ten set of ten homo recognized
entities but in the government there is
also another umbrella colonization with
all styles so we have two Miki Aikido we
have tendra Aikido we have your cencon
of course the majority of the population
- in Aikido 90% like iti but 10% other
styles and that and they were together
within the system that the instructor
license is for everyone the same of
course to keep the relation intact that
I cry I cry right we have a separate
umbrella concept for I only hiked I and
that can happen in Holland question from
the history in Holland we have the
Catholics and Protestants and the
Socialists and the combination and the
state so different silos of work right
and they learn to cooperate some out
together if you go to Britain where at
that time Chiba was the main influence
of Aikido after Kira died
and I mean he left actually to America
and give to stick to Connecticut and say
that we came very fragmented and so you
need in the beginning model if there's a
very strong leader like Chiba or Tamura
or Yamada you see a time that everything
is progressing very well and there's
also an limit to that and you see always
that's a point when they left or later I
see the split in common I mean it so
it's a whole government's system that
changes when those old sensei
leave because who are you gonna send to
replace them there is nobody that could
be sent so that is also let's say your
ID but also of course the the the the
current situation of Aikido itself
because of course in the beginning there
are all disciples of our sensei right so
they have this beginning spirited the
torch is in line laying life in them but
10 years later from now nobody's left
anymore what has been the size or sense
indirect so that is a different
challenge right because everyone
survived Aiko we have to find different
ways how we can maintain this this this
torch everywhere and means also not less
strong leaders so we have to find a way
to cooperate together if I could want to
continue to the list so we'll be talking
about less of a vertical organization
and more horizontal one by by default no
but but the vertical line can be still
very strong towards let's say I cry
itself the grading system but the way
you have to operate in your country to
where you treat your neighbors that's a
horror sort of issue and that like I
more more also aware of that that should
happen they tend to have in beginning
first of all only vertical eyes but now
they see that to be only for article
creates conflict by itself so now you
see also a tendency that they insist
that they cooperate
I think that's the only way we can
survive in the future actually otherwise
we get smaller and smaller silos
everywhere right but smaller and smaller
size means that the quality goes down
very quickly because I mean you know
yourself if you train only your own dojo
with maybe 30 people after some time you
know each other completely how you move
how you only fall and the progression
comes if you go outside and come back
right you have to fresh blood exchange
with other people so that's what I see
also now I'm up in the lens that the
John generation they they learn now from
the general ratio is not six seven done
and they don't care more where they with
lineage they are and they train together
then less busy with flack they take but
the downside of it by doing that it's
very difficult for them to understand
the lineage that you need a loyalty and
translation a long time to develop
yourself in Aikido if that disappears
was also a kind of vertical line right
we diminish of the qualify Aikido by
itself so the new generation let's say
in France or whatever in France rustic
dance who were never been to home
barracks that exists so what creates dip
down it by itself right
but it means if you don't create that
notion of vertical in your own Dorian
Federation yesterday you can keep not to
draw off your favorite together that's
what I see so let's say for me the
vertical line and the horse drawn line
what was normally the way to describe it
is determined like the cross right and
then Christianity dictate the cross you
can carry and what does not suffocate
you but there are two kind of crosses
the one right about here when when
another one here right so
so that kind of symbolic learns me that
the intersection of the vertical line in
the water line at that point that the
new leadership somebody you can combine
the two of them and that of course let's
say in the old times some good very
excellent Japanese teachers were not
able to take care of the horse on line
right so that wasn't reason to split so
that's and the modern generation they
expect you to communicate more and more
right so there you see that also in that
sense the notion I could change to to
come more in communication with others
when we see I mean I think when you talk
about communication these days on the
number of issue this is coming it's
becoming like a really landmine with you
know social networks and how huge
proportions of anything can take and you
know I'm not too sure that the aikikai
necessarily realizes I'll put the forms
that that ought to be to be put to
communicate on a wide big scale and my
question is does the IAF have any say in
itk communication when it tends to be
intended to go worldwide no although we
advise and just a matter of fact you
know you know nowadays all the social
medias can spread around information
very quick and it's always a search what
the to information was not true and
what's that not valid so I hate forums
in the sense because you can easily
deliver your opinion without any
background often that you you really
have grounds in it so for me it is not
not a good way but friends we're not
benefit from the position now as the
undersecretary if' I am we know busy to
make a new website because the website
is you know outdated in technology and
one of the Eid s we know what we present
next week to the ike guys that we give
an open window for that guy in our
website so that they somehow can use our
website also because what we see of what
i see is that the the way I like to use
social media is let's say old-fashioned
right and I'm already old fashioned I'm
60 I'm not the generation of social
media but I can see that they have
difficulty to modernize it in such a way
that is that is like accessible on a
professional level how he could use
social media I mean like dude this
interview is a kind of tool to do that
and I think that's the only way for the
future how to survive also Aikido we
have to be visible on screens but what
we deliver as on the screen should be of
course
[Music]
you